mais pourquoi personne ne me croit quand
je dis que j'ai couché avec jessica alba
pourquoi direct techniquement je suis un
prince mais on peut dire que je suis le
kim de ces dames parce que je les écoute
j'ai embrassé cendrillon tiana jeu les
pires bien embrasser m6 vous dit made in
china représentent les quartiers far
west et buzz de mongoliens tout ce que
tu veux faire c'est faire le base ball
tu veux te lâches mais apprend à parler
moi j'ai plus de pain phrase
digitalisées loser mon plastique à moi
c'est du béton et poté rembourrés avec
du coton tétouan c'est les chats
invisible qui part quitte avec le
problème avec les adultes c'est qu'ils
ont la mémoire courte et pas d'humour
vous les jeunes avec vos blagues pipi
caca vous êtes ridicule il ya des
blagues sur hit beaucoup plus dit la
rote j'ai embrassé à titi rennes mais là
j'ai fait que l'on brasse et parce que
les filles qu'on est que je c'est pareil
moi j'ai pas peur de toi tu es missiles
sont en place le buzz buzz là mais ça
fait moche c'est pareil tu as des
moulures sous les barres et crois moi
c'est pathétique vas-y bec me parle pas
sert l'infini et au delà
elle avait loué dans non ça doit pendant
qu'elle dormait les tudors comme j'en
passe et blanche neige
jean marc saladin excusez moi c'est
kanye west qui aura des photos du cul de
kim et ils comptent elles ont rappelé à
m on est trop pote a été ni trop peu et
d'ailleurs j'ai cru un moment que ça
allait partir entre y sommes avec lui la
semaine mais malheureusement elles fm
j'ai théâtre a fait petit latin suite eu
le temps de se coucher vers spa clan
votre empire a jeté par une petite
souris et geppetto gpt cépétois gttp bri